call me dude Z Adam Driver who's one of
our finest actors does some incredible
breath acting in this movie unbelievable
yes at the beginning he's like this
I'm I'm never gonna get home this whole
thing's shattered I can't communicate
with whomever I don't know where I am
and he takes the like a gun and he's
about to blow his head off and then he
at the last second thinks of his
daughter and he stops and he goes
[Music]
three times yeah there's a lot of
pantomime and stuff family family family
family
but there's also a lot of him going
yeah it's actually a good actor
discipline because most people like okay
hey what are we getting this when's
lunch and they forget it's like no
you're up yeah you got up
I'm up I'm on Earth but it's 65
million years ago there's dinosaurs
after me what I need some Tronics